sûrement ça va tu as quel âge déjà toi à
toi pas aimé la réponse on pourra faire
c'est qu'on va répondre directement à la
grande question tout le monde se pose
comme ça sera fait donc à quel âge est
ce qu on devient vieux et bien la
réponse c'est qu'il n'y a pas de réponse
à cette question
ah là là là on partait pas tout de suite
je vais quand même vous expliquer deux
trois trucs dans certaines publications
médicales on parle de 75 ans pour les
nations unies se serait même 60 ans mais
en vérité tout ça ça veut rien dire
la médecine fait des progrès nos
habitudes de vie changent
l'environnement aussi l'espérance de vie
augmente tout ça c'est en évolution
permanente
par contre qu'on sait c'est que notre
corps commence à décliner à partir de 30
ans ça pique un bar et mais c'est comme
ça ça s'appelle le processus domeo
sténose et ça commence à partir de la
trentaine là encore c'est une moyenne
donc on va commencer par se dire qu est
vieux en vrai ça n'existe pas et qu'on
est juste tout ça un stade de notre
vieillissement différents mais bon on va
quand même voir ce qui nous attend
d'abord il ya ce qu'on peut appeler les
effets physiologiques du vieillissement
notre corps c'est un peu comme une
machine qui est composée plein de pièces
qui s'usent au fur et à mesure plus ou
moins selon les personnes
il y en a certains qu'on peut remplacer
et d'autres pas on commence par les
facultés sensorielles les organes qui
sont liées à chacun de nos cinq sens
vieillissent et ils peuvent modifier
notre perception du monde extérieur
la vision très diminue progressivement à
cause de ce qu'on appelle la presbytie
et des maladies du cristallin ou du nerf
optique peuvent la rendre flous ou
diminuer le champ visuel périphériques
voilà ça donne à peu près ça les
structures de l'oreille interne s'abîme
aussi et peuvent entraîner une
presbyacousie c'est à dire une baisse de
l'audition du coup sentant un peu comme
ça et les bruits trop fort ça peut
provoquer des acouphènes
non je dis les bruits trop fort ça peut
côté bouche le nombre de papilles
gustatives diminue la sensibilité aux
odeurs aussi ce qui peut modifier le
goût des aliments
tout ça a lié à la diminution de la
taille de l'estomac et aux problèmes
dentaires ça explique pourquoi les
personnes âgées ont parfois moins
d'appétit et enfin il ya les mécanos
récepteur qui sont responsables du
toucher leur nombre diminue les fibres
nerveuses qui sont chargés de passer
l'information elle s'altère et la peau
perd en élasticité
du coup la sensibilité du toucher baisse
qui peut perturber la manipulation des
objets mais aussi la faculté à sentir
correctement le sol sous ses pieds
globalement avec le vieillissement tous
les organes perte de leur souplesse et
leur élasticité et les grandes fonctions
vitales ont tendance à se modifier ou à
se ralentir c'est là pour le coeur et
les poumons qui supporte moins bien
l'effort la vessie et les sphincters qui
deviennent moins fiables l'intestin qui
devient paresseux les muscles qui
perdent de leur force les articulations
qui deviennent plus raides et moins
mobiles et le cerveau qui diminue de
volume mais en marge du vieillissement
physiologique c'est toute notre vie qui
détermine la personne âgée qu'on va
devenir notre patrimoine génétique mais
aussi ce qu'on mange ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on fume le métier qu'on fait les
maladies qu'on a et leurs séquelles les
médicaments qu'on prend et leurs effets
secondaires les médicaments comprend
contre les effets secondaires des
premiers médicaments comprend la donne
j'arrête là je vous sens pas bien rester
serein ce genre de catalogue ça fait
toujours peur mais en vrai personne
développe l'intégralité de tous ces
troubles en tout cas pas avec
l'intensité maximale en plus ça vient
progressivement donc on a le temps de
s'y adapter et il ya plein de moyens de
se soigner ou de limiter les
inconvénients
en fait je veux surtout pas vous faire
peur l'idée c'est plutôt de se mettre
deux secondes à la place d'une personne
âgée imaginer ce qu'elle vit ce qu'elle
ressent ce qu'elle perçoit et 12 y
adapter leur en étant un peu indulgents
un peu patient et on le chasse il tend
un peu la vie parce que la pire maladies
du vieillissement c'est l'isolément
c'est aussi pour ça quand on est âgé on
va faire ses courses en même temps que
tout le monde c'est pas pour faire chier
alors même si la petite dame devant vous
et elle a du mal à compter ses pièces et
s'il me siècle et cheveux blancs il
prend cinq minutes pour parler avec la
caissière
soyez cool n'est pas à cinq minutes près
et on s'est peut-être leurs cinq minutes
de contact humain de la journée
bon allez pour vous rassurer il ya aussi
plein de choses qui changent pas et
qu'on peut garder longtemps comme le
sens de l'humour par exemple les
émotions aussi un cadeau comme l' envie
de s'amuser de chanter de danser et
surtout le plaisir de partager des bons
moments avec les gens qu'on aime et
quand je dis partager des bons moments
avec les gens qu'on aime je parle pas
seulement des clac et une boîte de pâte
de feuillus goûter avec ses
petits-enfants theory est ce que je veux
dire oui je parle de sexe ouais ouais
les personnes âgées ont une sexualité
alors bon si vous avez la chance qu'ils
soient encore en vie vous avez peut-être
pas envie d'imaginer vos grands parents
en plaine le vrai de claquer mais si on
prend la question autrement
vous serez peut-être assuré de vous dire
que vous quand vous serez vieux vous
pourrez continuer à pratiquer le sexe la
libido
c'est à dire le désir l'envi de copuler
pour ce qu'on appelle atteint ça
s'arrête pas à l'âge de la retraite
bien sûr faut s'adapter aux changements
physiques dont on a déjà parlé et à ceux
qui sont liés à la ménopause et à
l'andropause landreau causé la ménopause
des hommes on n'en parle pas souvent
mais ça existe
bon on oublie d'intégrale du kama sutra
en un seul qu il ya d'autres moyens de
s'amuser et quand on veut on peut
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que vieillir
c'est pas une maladie et que du coup les
personnes âgées ceni des malades ni
desous personne c'est juste vous dans
quelques années et ça va bien se passer
mais pour les choses plus concrètes
voilà ce qu'on va faire je vais devenir
vieux le temps d'une journée et je vous
montre ce que ça donne dans une
prochaine vidéo
mais l'attitude dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui je reviens très vite
d'ici là à passer un peu de temps avec
les personnes âgées qui vous entoure et
pour kevin